- Récession, le mot qui fait
fr l l les démocrates.
Inflation. Des mots que
martèlent les campagnes
publicitaires républicaines...
... à 26 jours des élections
de mi-mandat, car la réalité
économique sur le terrain
fait mal.
"L'essence, le panier
d'épicerie, les loyers,
tout augmente" dit ce chauffeur
de taxi.
À New York, c'est la flambée
des prix. Le prix des loyers
a augmenté de 35 %, en moyenne
au pays, l'augmentation est de
14 %. Quant au prix de l'essence
même s'il a baissé depuis juin,
il recommence à augmenter.
"on n'y arrive pas ce chauffeur
uber. Je ne fais jamais le plan.
Je paie 5 à 10 $ à chaque
course. Maudit Biden", dit-il
. Ils blâment tous la Russie,
mais c'est lui le responsable.
"C'est difficile d'y arriver,
dit-celle-ci, même avec un
emploi à temps plein, ce n'est
plus assez". Elle aussi fait
du uber eats pour boucler
les fins de mois.
Le panier d'épicerie a augmenté
en moyenne de 8 % en un an.
"Mon meilleur index, ce sont
mes 3 L de bacon, dit-il,
ça me coûtait 11 $ en promotion,
aujourd'hui, c'est presque
le double, même en solde".
Le dernier sondage indique que
78 % des américains trouvent
la situation économique
lamentable, et 52 % sont
insatitststs du président Biden.
"Les électeurs sont inquiets
dit-elle, sommes nous en
récession, l'inflation
préoccupe les Américains".
"Non, répond Joe Biden, tous les
six mois, ils disent qu'on va en
récession, ce n'est pas encore
arrivé, si ça arrive,
ce sera une légère récession".
Une possible récession avec
comme toile de fond la campagne
électorale. Ce serait
de mauvaise augure pour les
démocrates qui pourraient
perdre le contrôle du congrès.
Les démocrates misent surtout
sur la question de l'avortement
pour remporter ces élections.
Ici, en Virginie, la candidate
démocrate Abigail Spanberger
fait campagne surtout sur
la question de l'avortement.
Sa campagne publicitaire attaque
sa rivale républicaine qui est
anti-avortement même en cas
de viol.
"Elle ne comprend pas que la
vérité, la réalité que quelqu'un
qui est une victime de la
violation peut être enceinte.
C'est incroyable, mais c'est
la vérité qui existe
dans cette campagne."
Sa rivale républicaine Yesli
Vega martèle le même message
sur l'économie, la criminalité
et les migrants.
Même Bernie Sanders a la
un avertissement aux démocrates,
affirmant qu'ils font fausse
route en misant seulement
sur l'avortement pour gagner
ces élections.
"Il faut arreter de miser
seulement sur l'avortement pour
gagner ces élections, dit-il,
c'est la situation économique
qui préoccupe les américains